okay welcome so we've all seen these
wonderful polished presentations this is
not one of those this is going to be one
of those will probably fall flat on its
face will crack a few jokes and pretend
it never happened that kind of thing
because it's working
yes okay so here we go let's try that
one one more time so you will see those
wonderful polished presentations that go
as smooth as clockwork this is not going
to be like that so all right you all you
guys you you work in the real world and
do real things right and you all have
insane deadlines and stuff like that yes
take one step into the cryptocurrency
world and it gets ten times worse which
is why we will wing it at times but we
will we will do what we can to give you
an idea of what is possibly one of the
most exciting areas in software tech but
exists today and if you disagree with me
fine you're probably a lot saner than I
am anyway okay so I will introduce Ramon
hello everyone that's this guy he is
young good-looking and then there's me
Dave I am ancient and falling apart
Ramon runs a thing called crypto job a
list which is a site where if you decide
that you're foolish enough to want to
get into this kind of technology go
there find a job and never look
back I work for a little company in
Malaysia between hello gold we were
started to try to help people in like
the countries of this region in
particular hedge some of their savings
into something which wasn't quite as
volatile as the currency right now many
of you are quite young you may not
remember 1997 the Asian currency crisis
I started the business two weeks before
it started because I have got an amazing
sense of timing in Malaysia people
people who found their savings went down
to 50 percent of the value right in
Indonesia it was a heck of a lot less
than that in Thailand it was a lot worse
so it so our CEO was was the former
chief financial officer of the world
Gold Council he used to run spider gold
which is the world's largest gold based
ETF and he is trying to bring that same
concept to ordinary people because also
in the countries I've named not like
Singapore it's very hard for ordinary
guys to have access to any kind of
decent investments so that's what we
exist for to allow people to buy gold
save gold yeah so if the currency tanks
you've still got something of value
right that being said we are we are we
did Raman created a telegram group the
solidity workshop on telegram if you if
you had telegram you join into that at
some point we will ask you to send us
information and we'll send you back some
tests either for various networks and
things like that so when you get there
when we get there
into it right yep so enough of this
sweet-talking let's get into the
business so here we go
what we're going to try to do is theorem
smart contracts from basically zero to
deployment in approximately three hours
because we've wasted the first 30
minutes waffling on yeah okay here we go
so the roadmap what are they gonna cover
hopefully right first one first five
minutes what's the blockchain all about
who knows what block chains are I
thought so okay cool
we're smart contract to come in this is
like where the theorem is really strong
something called smart contracts if you
haven't heard about them you will soon
then decentralization and a whole other
technical stuff you'll see it when we
get to it don't worry about it until we
get that right so
so
what we expect you to learn what these
are in blockchains about a very very
slight roughness which is a programming
language not much really you know during
this without loads of random things
which will which part in the notes we're
going to try and point you to some
resources one of weeks ago the VR
telegram channel you can ask questions
we will respond why security is
important possibly a lot more so than in
anything that you've worked on before
and the biggest name we've got is that
you get enough to get you interested to
find out the next step
that's the important bit because for a
lot of people right you take that that
first baby step takes a lot more courage
through the next big leap right oh it's
that thing that you keep putting off
once you've got an inkling of what you
can do with it
yeah you then start thinking well I
better allocate allocate a bit more time
so that's where we're going
so basics of a blockchain in five
minutes
by the strange sense of time if I get it
wrong don't hold me to it right
a blockchain is a load of sign of
transactions stuffed into blocks which
are signed and linked to the previous
block so that everybody agrees that is
that is correct
that's it
is that five-minute no okay sorry okay
so what's the transaction well
there you go that's a transaction from
me to Rahman I send him a coffee and I'd
say oh I tell him why I'm doing it
because otherwise I'm you might fall
asleep right fair enough
I've got coffee okay so assuming that he
doesn't drink the bloody coffee yeah at
the end of the day he's got one coffee
earth one coffee more I've got one
coffee left and we keep on doing this
meeting and everything right and at the
end of the day we all know how much
coffee he reveals he's got long as we
start at the beginning we probably have
to have a transaction make the coffee in
there somewhere but these are these are
transactions right um so yeah but this
is like an accounting ledger yes
so what's the big deal well the big deal
is that but what the first big deal is
that that sounds actually is signed so
do you know what digital signatures are
I see look
okay let's have someone shout out no no
there we go so you learn all these new
signatures are you know our hash
functions are though don't you because
you never store passwords in the claim
in the plane you store an md5 hash or or
a char whatever hash or ever yes yeah
yes good right so if I take a hash of
that piece of data assuming I've got a
good hash function nobody can miss with
the data right so now I've got something
that's foolproof right except for the
fact that if you wanted to change the
data you change the hash as well so that
still is it was still reliable yes so it
still doesn't work so the next thing you
do is okay so but otherwise if you
couldn't mess with the hash the Hat
would prove the validity of the data
right because you can recompute the hash
on the data the data is valid yes
right um so yeah because I I give you
the piece of data and the hash you
recompute the how to do for to match yes
wonderful
right so the second part is we encrypt
the hash with the sender's private key
do you know what encryption is kinda
right you know what public key private
key is it's the thing behind all the SS
ssh technology and that sort of stuff
it's allowing the complicated
mathematics i take a piece of data i do
a mathematical transformation with it
with one random number from that random
number i can derive a second number that
you can use to decrypt it which I can
tell anybody has a proper public key or
you can encrypt it with a public key and
I can read it with a private key
right so in this case if I encrypt the
hash with my private key and I'd let you
know what my public key is I in this
case it will be the sender right because
I've used my address which is my public
key so if I say it from my public key
and I encrypt it with my private key
anyone can check that transaction is
valid right because my public key is
part of the message in plain text right
so you can see my public to my public
key you can decrypt the encrypted hash
to get the correct hash and you can
prove that the decrypted hash matches
the hash that you would compute for the
data that's the digital signature there
is no magic to it and when we talk about
crypto currencies and all that stuff
it's the only place that could the
cryptography takes place anywhere in
anything but the most advanced
blockchain
right so it's all about digital
signatures if that goes over your head
read about it a bit otherwise I won't
have the five minutes but that's the
very basics right otherwise think of it
as a signature but it means that the
nobody nobody can forge a transaction
from me and there we go page two
right we stick em in blocks at least it
new blocks well I just assembled them
into some kind of an array type
structure some kind of a database record
and I who put that block together for
the link to the previous block that I
signed the block and if you put one
together you do the same thing you sign
the block so we know who did it
right so that if if you have got this
block you can go to the previous block
check the previous block is where they
go to the previous block and so on this
there's a little bit more complicated
stuff she does actually have to
re-evaluate the whole block chain right
but from this and that block you can
until the entire block chain is valid
in a manner which everybody agrees upon
and I'm sure you've heard things about
how one blockchain transaction costs
about person
costs about as much as it does to heat
the entire United States for a couple of
hours or something like that right the
block the block check the blockchain
consumers about as much as the state of
Denmark or something like that um I'm
gonna skip that right the method for
having the consensus is let's call it
magic for a minute because I think it's
not important for where we coming from
but the technology is there so that the
entire members yeah everybody all the
nodes on the blockchain agree that the
same chain is a valid so that if you put
on one block you put on another block
all right you both try and have
something to the blockchain
there is a means of arbitration to
decide which one is valid and then you
try again to get the next block right so
now we have a I'm sorry Mike I'm walking
around I'm making your life difficult
okay so now we have a means of ensuring
that our ledger is consistent agreed by
everybody
now once we have a ledger the degree
buyers won't even know how much
everybody's got right there blockchain
five minutes what's that yeah yeah
that's your five minutes cool okay so
we're the smart contract to come into
this because that's the bit that makes
aetherium worth doing right
because what I've just discussed is kind
of like the technology between bit
behind ripple from Bitcoin and all these
other things right we're really all that
you are talking about is a ledger system
that is storing value right bitcoins and
face it's not a real Bitcoin bitcoin is
out there in me so what's the difference
ethereal well let's have another look um
I said I'm silly ramen of coffee because
otherwise he might fall asleep he
doesn't drink coffee
he's one of these new freedoms I suppose
most of you this newbie the pro
Montgomery don't think coffee never
months now so that is a whole load of
bytes right it's a data field and those
among you who have had more fun in
program who think but hang on it's a
data field we can do something with that
right because that's what you do you
right yeah I mean an HTML webpage is
only a piece of data but a web browser
interprets it and does something fancy
right and so on so yeah maybe we could
do something with that like interpret it
as byte code that's the thought right
now once we got to that we we started
aetherium where we said okay if i send a
transaction to you or you or you or you
it's a transaction to one of you people
normal but what happens if I send it to
address zero that the address that
nobody can actually own then what it
does is it takes my it takes that data
and it stores it and it says and it
gives it an address and says anyone can
send anything they like to this now and
you have what's called a smart
contractors although the bytes but if
theorem has a virtual machine right much
like
which basically is interprets the
bytecode right so yeah but you know you
you will use virtual machines you know
I'm talking about right I mean typical
interpreter virtual machines out there
will be like microsoft.net framework
Java compiles down to byte codes we see
what makes it portable right so um once
you've done that you have a smart
contract now a smart contract you can
send things to your smart contract you
can send instructions to your smart
contract you can send value right so I
mentioned before the Bitcoin you know
it's just a value right so I send you
point 1 of a Bitcoin or something like
that you can send half a Bitcoin to
someone else
II thought also of etherium also has is
own native currency which is either
that's how you send at the value but you
can also send messages in the data so
the first thing we talked about was me
putting a contract out there in code
with which a program encoded in the bike
in the data the next thing I can also do
is send parameters send you know like a
rest a rest call where you where you put
what the contract address would be the
www dot and then you've got the path
which becomes the method name you're
trying to call in the contract and after
that you encode the data right so we
could weaken we can specify which
function we want to call and we can send
it parameter
yeah go go for it um now code on the
blockchain can be seen by anybody so
yeah if you've been happily setting up
an ojs server you're used to the fact
that nobody can see your code unless you
publish it on github write code on the
blockchain everything on the blockchain
name can be seen by anybody
what if anybody knows what they're doing
um so if I publish I mean the first step
is I can publish when I publish a
contract a fantastic little thing called
a blocking Stora ether scan would allow
you to see the creation of the contract
it's saying it will say this is the code
which is not that fantastic but I mean
that is the source code of a contract I
thought remember which one but that's
the source code of a contract right that
gets submitted it becomes a contract and
you can send transactions to it and
people who communicate with it oh sorry
yeah you can verify the source code of
course because once you put it on the
blockchain ethos can allow you to upload
the source code which it compiles with
the same versus the compiler and it
makes sure that the output matches the
code that you sent if it does they
publish the source code so now anyone
can see your source code this is a token
and it's on the blockchain somewhere and
if you interact with it using a block
Explorer you can see every single
interaction with that contract there is
no privacy on the hood chain right
unless you build it in so I mean of
course you can put the encrypted data on
there which only other people who knows
how to unencrypted it will be able to
get hold of but people can see that you
put it there they can see who put it
there right so these are transactions on
the blockchain it tells you they've got
block numbers you've got when they were
posted who they're from who it was sent
to
well we don't how am i doing for time
okay get I still got a few minutes left
yeah good address tactic okay so
people refer to blockchain environments
as decentralized crustless you built on
odious application right everybody has
to trust you
right if you do an online banking
application they probably has to trust
that it works that it's not going to
steal your funds
nobody can verify it unless you give
them access to the source code and since
they can't see in your source code the C
inside of your server they also have to
trust that the source code you given
them is the same source code you've
currently deployed on the blockchain you
can see exactly what's been deployed you
can see every single transaction it is
designed to create systems where people
can interact because they know what they
are interacting with they know how so I
can see your source code I can see your
contract if I want to I can get someone
to audit that contract for me to prove
that it but it actually does what it
says it does and then I can interact
with it
of course normally I would trust your
contract is okay sometimes they're not
right so what is more to the point where
is that contract on the blockchain
whereabouts geographically because like
yo you've got yours of an OG a server in
an Amazon Center somewhere which will
they trust they're looking after somehow
right right we trust that all of the
services we use will not go down might
get lab yeah well I did something less
than that anyway so the point is that
you have central points of failure no
matter how hard you try you have central
points of failure right unless you have
ridiculous amounts of resources if I
deploy contacts the blockchain it is on
every single node of the Bob train so
it's on this computer here it's on
computers in Kansas Indonesia and Mexico
and Hawaiians pick a country yes right
it's all over the places on thousands if
not millions of nodes by now it's
auditable if you want interact with my
contract you don't talk to my server
anymore you talk talk to a server to a
server near you you talk to your own
notebook your notebook communicates all
the other ones it says this is what I
intend to do and as long as it's it's a
it's a legal thing to do it will get
shared amongst all the other nodes
now there are multiple reasons for doing
blockchain I have the Long Island to
blockchain company know one of them is
to make your company sexy for investors
even though you do nothing to do with
the blockchain so people throw money at
you but since we're all technical people
we walk away from such things of course
we do it because it's fun so multiple
actors multiple people involved in it
who do not necessarily want to have to
thrust each other or who where yeah
where it's easy if everything's out
there so everything could be audited
without any problems right some
conflicting interests right so it would
be no yeah there's no point say Zul and
me setting up something to take your
money and say we would give you
something in return if someone I best
buddies
so but then if we've got a few other
people involved so luck in the case of
Heather gold with you know obviously
there's us there's our voting age of
dealing with the gold we allow you to
pledge your gold to take loans because
also we find that like in Malaysia 75%
of all loans get rejected so we say if
you've managed to save some gold you can
use it against the luck as collateral
for a loan right so we've got the loan
and for the loan party we've got digital
wallets that we work with like Cellcom
IX er - one of the largest regional
telecommunication we've got lots of
people involved in our system now so we
have multiple actors some proof lifting
interests right so for us you know if
you know it's it's good for us to get
everybody having loads of proved but of
course a on credit want to make sure
that the people have got enough gold and
it can be locked up until they learn to
pay it off right so there's a
conflicting interest there and of course
there have to be some common goals
otherwise nobody's going to use it
so that is my a sensible reason for
doing it if there's only one person
involved in it if you are going to be
saving records for your own personal use
you can't see how anybody else would be
interested in it and even if they are
you could just stick it up in a blog
post there's no point doing a blog chain
okay
if only one person ever interacts with
it it's a database right
[Music]
so now we've got this bytecode and
nobody-nobody there may be four or five
people out there who are even further
off into the land of traces than I am so
very few people right right you know
right pure bytecode very few people
right assembler they all use a language
of these the languages are solidity
which is inspired by JavaScript serpent
was something which came from Python
which they've now getting rid of because
it was hard to make it secure viper is
something which is new and unstable lll
lots of people who got their different
names for it low-level language lovely
the floor anguish I don't know what it
stands for not many people use it people
can use assembler the etherium virtual
machine is a stack machine most people
use solidity which as I say is inspired
by JavaScript but you should get you all
taking a pretty big sigh of relief right
because you've all got an advantage here
okay so we're going to talk about
solidity solidity is used to
write programs or write contracts
contracts are a little bit like objects
as in object inheritance C++ or Java
type thing right I hope most of us have
been into other areas
I believe that JavaScript doesn't have
objects quite like that does it
you'll have to correct me here sorry I
have done JavaScript a few times over
the years but my mind has moved on it is
close enough good right so think of it
like a class right so it contracts a bit
like class it has a constructor we got
constructors
yeah causing your constructor parameters
you've got functions that do things
you've got functions that don't do
things they just tell you something yeah
like yeah what's the price of tea today
nope you don't actually change anything
to get the price it to you just right
we have persistent state data which you
must have right I'm sure if anybody can
if if I'm saying something and you can
think of the right word in JavaScript to
describe it shout it out right so what's
the state data for a class in in
JavaScript
[Music]
yeah I said some I have two functions
someone calls the first box and they
change something when the second
function actually can still see that
change data or do you call that instance
data yeah okay so state state state data
is instance data in JavaScript right and
of course you've got local variables and
things which get thrown away the moment
you leave the functions we can also talk
from one contract to another just like
you can have one one object called
another object bingo so it's a language
that's not entirely unlike JavaScript
and if I show you that you say to
yourself this is JavaScript right yeah
yeah good
if I talk rubbish you can throw things
if you can't hear me tell me the talker
Oh like a few minutes Q&A are you guys
following questions so far there have
been a few questions in chat yeah yeah
let's leave let's leave the caveat page
shall we telegram it's Kenny go it's
like t dot me slash selenium workshop
that's uh let's back it up yeah I go all
the way but okay yeah there you go okay
that's coming real soon
yeah um anybody else got anything before
I know come on come on guys this is not
a thing of all classroom isn't it any
question this probably could not make
any sense at all
we will now trying to find exactly where
I was so where were you were well you
guys managed to get to the telegram
group shall we get a few min one minutes
okay yeah so we're gonna get into it
very very now just after like I just
after this page here right so as you can
see solidity is exactly like JavaScript
right except a conscious yeah actually I
forgot that so you come there should be
a semicolon there's quite yeah right um
I didn't test it I nobody test my code I
didn't test out very sorry okay except
for the fact that
okay contracts well we know about
contracts contracts alert classes that's
their gas that's the fun one when you
interact with anything on the blockchain
to change anything on the blockchain you
have to pay for it
because blockchain is stored stored on
muscle computers across the network
there are computers making there are
people out there making sure that a
network but the blockchain stays
consistent and they're all doing a lot
of work to do that and they get paid for
it
so if you want to interact with a conch
with a contract in such a way that it
changes anything whether it's just me
sending ether to somebody or whether it
is me changing of changing data before
something like that
have to pay for it because it goes into
my local no my local node shares it
across the entire thousands and
thousands of nodes and they all agree
and say yep that's vital all they say no
you can't do that so you have to pay for
it you pay for it in ether and it's
called gas how much you pay for
transaction depends upon number one how
much work is involved some things take
more computing power than others or more
storage space so you pay more if you're
going to use a lot of storage space you
pay more if you've got like a lot of
computation and the second thing is an
incentivization thing where you actually
decide how much you want to pay per unit
of gas
now you do that because if you're
putting a transaction out there someone
has to mine it and the person who mines
it gets paid the transaction fees but if
you're prepared to pay more you can get
priority right so you pay for every
transaction the types are a bit
different
we don't have integers all the most
common things in a theorem are addresses
which is 256 bit value and a 256 bit
unsigned integer yeah I don't believe
they even have signed integers do they
or if they do I've never seen anybody
using them Eric the chief currency is a
256 bit unsigned integer how about
floating points well for floating point
numbers are usually dealt with as two
unfitted six bit unsigned integers where
the last 18 decimal points are regarded
as fractions right they are talking
about at some point they might have
fixed point numbers just for fun sorry
Mike right
every transaction if it succeeds can
create and I can interact with events to
log information that you can see it
normally if you do something it's the
only way you can find out what goes on
you make a log or you can examine the
state of the contract oh I did mention
when you interact with a contract there
is the other thing you could do you
could yes I say if you if you want to
know the value of something you want to
do something that does not involve
changing state you don't need to query
the whole network you can only you can
query a local node that is free right
you don't have to pay to make a query
you only have to pay to change things
because your node should be in exactly
the same state as everybody else is mode
so you can query the state a state
memory like this the persistent memory
cost money in yes right recursion not
advisable
all right we all know that you know all
programmers have won't have any fun
start thinking about recursion please
not in not in solidity this only God is
only got a limited stack size to start
with maybe you can speed up for this
section of this okay okay this section
you're quite right yeah so there are a
whole lot of other things a lot of it's
about okay the key ones you have to
specify if your contracts going to
receive ether the contract the can't
that you do not specify to receive ether
there's something says ether to it it
will be will reject it what else ASCII
okay this is probably this is probably
the best one here multiple values you
can return multiple values can you do
that in JavaScript the function returns
two values oh we got that okay fine it
is all right and you can throw the last
very important thing you can at any
point in the execution of a function the
function can say if this happens roll
back roll back the entire transaction so
it doesn't matter what's happened to how
how much information has changed up to
this point if something happens throw it
all away do not change anything right so
that you do you have a require or assert
or either do a revert yeah okay let's go
where are we okay so things required for
a contract the first line of your
contract will say that it will specify
the solidity version you're using it has
to be above a certain version right the
latest version so far is four zero point
four point 19 so if I put that as my top
line I can't use an older compiler to
build it you can have includes we know
about includes right you you specify the
contract like specifying your class you
just you you do your state variables we
have modifiers now modify
fun modifiers are conditions that are
required to execute a function so only
the owner of the contract can execute
this or you can only execute this if
it's after January the 26th things like
that
I mean oh sorry about that we should be
on silent imagine it's on silent well
look at well look at the rest I think
well I think we have most of the things
in the next few lines right now at this
point I'm going to take you through
writing a very simple contract or at
least I'm not going to get you to write
it I'm going to get you to copy it if
you look at on github gist s-- there is
a contract called buy gold under golden
Dave on if you load that way and you go
to and you you open a browser tab
another tab preferably to remix etherion
double
I shared the link in the if you're in
chat life is cool
pretty cute now if you do that you have
an interactive environment for messing
around with contracts and
it allows you so what I'm suggesting
that you do is you create a new tab in
remix you copy the code from the gist
and stick it in there and then we can
all be on the same kind of page
right so I'm not going to talk about all
of this all of this contract because I
actually got to two contracts there one
talks to the other I'm not going to talk
about using the second one just the
first one that you can play with it so
this the second contract is designed to
interact with the first round that's all
I'm going to say that are we the
information is anything in the thing
right yeah okay so if we can go to the
next page then right now what a remix is
designed to not only work in an
interactive mode it can also talk to the
blockchain using something called web 3j
s which Roman has promised me it's going
to tell you about later
but at the moment we're going to work in
an emulated environment using the
JavaScript VM so on the settings page
you will see is its settings page or the
sorry on the run page you have the
environment JavaScript VM and you have
got about 10 different accounts yes
what sorry oh sorry okay five accounts
enough to play with anyway right now use
the JavaScript VM use the first of those
accounts and take the con take the
contract exchange rate and click now
you've got to give it two addresses here
all right so I think I'm gonna have to
get out of my present mode a little bit
the showing how we doing so far guys any
questions I did his live one who's going
to get difficult okay yeah so I just you
do the talking order the doing you try
to explain what I'm doing I'm cool so we
were mixing is like interactive
environment where you can interact with
your
that's not what people really use in
like the day-to-day
if you're an engineer anymore solidity
engineering work but it's like a really
nice interactive environment where you
can like really quickly test ideas and
maybe debug contracts as well so remix
the theory of network have everyone
loaded it racing hands who loaded the
this editor in their browser right okay
excellent excellent okay so you got this
tiny plus here you could add a new add a
new term I'm sure you figure that up by
now you add a new tab you paste the code
into this term on the right everyone's
on that everyone entering the companies
that need just once you've done it you
may need to compile it by clicking upon
this button in the compile tab to start
to compile and if all goes well it says
says okay groovy we've done it anyone
having them is it not compiled a felon
now compiling
so can you have a look at the guys whose
code is your money yeah it's all good
yeah that's right it's okay right so we
go to the run tab there are various
options here injective web 3 or talking
to a web 3 provide that music you talk
to a node on your own computer I can do
my best to zoom right there we go
however so you have got source we're
going to use the JavaScript VM later on
Rama's going to talk about using meta
masked which would be injected web 3 but
the world will stick with the JavaScript
VM do you have got five accounts that
you can use for sending transactions
each of them has got a hundred virtual
ether that you can pay for things with
right is that it back there
prescients so we start with we're gonna
start with the first count them you just
cleared that one right so we're going to
create exchange rates
now what under create is says there are
two addresses which if I was going to
come over here a bit you will see under
exchange rate it has address gold source
address cache source right
how am I looking that I could look here
right sorry ignore me right here we go
so I need two addresses so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to be using
three of my addresses here I'm going to
set the second address to be my gold
source my third address to be my cash
source right because it wants three
different accounts to interact with it
now
it's a bit finicky it what it wants
addresses and long numbers to be inside
quotes so why I normally do that is I
put my quotes in the first I'm thinking
to put in the third one which is that
you can just copy the address you can
paste it in you go back
you choose your second address you copy
that you paste that in right so I've got
two different addresses these of 0 X 1 4
4 B right okay then I click the Create
button it can it creates the object for
me so basically what do you when you hit
a create button right are you guys there
no okay so it leads to creates contact
within a DM within a in-memory
JavaScript VM that compiles letters into
bytecode and this thing is what do you
see in this area is just like interfaces
that he can interact with with the
contract is just like a nice UI that fur
makes provides you with later on we're
gonna go into like I mean just just like
some line text and I'm gonna show you
guys like you know you'll be able to
build the UI yourself and it's all gonna
make sense right so you can exam
variables the gold source this was the
address I created it this was the
address I put in the first one 0 1 4 you
can see the catch sauce down there
hey yeah okay you can see the two two
variables I put it in the constructor
the gold sauce and the cash sauce if you
just click on these two buttons and it
reveals the value so the blue buttons
are either looking at the value of a
variable or it is calling a constant
function that changes nothing
all variables in solidity are
initialized to false or zero now
depending upon what the type is right
go price in here let's give it let's
have a look at some of the code for a
minute we'll go back to this in terms of
what I was saying the first line tells
it the tells it that we are contract in
solidity compile it with 419 or higher
the second line declares the contract
you can have inheritance as I've said
before in which case you say exchange
rate is something else but if you're
interested you'll find that out right I
have got two addresses which are public
gold source and cash source now
the important thing about this is that
all public variables have getters
created for them
all right so you can read those values
so when you're talking from one function
to another you never actually interact
with the variable you're in turn
interact with the automatically created
getter right ah I have got two maps okay
let me tell you what I'm trying to do
here after we've launched the contract
so this is just an example from the kind
of stuff I do because I played this with
the stuff I'm familiar with right so
have a gold buy their gold in Singapore
from bullion star international they're
on North Bridge Road there there are a
decent voting agent rent what we're
selling in Malaysia so I've got two
things that affect the price of my gold
I've got the price I paid in Singapore
dollars and I've got the exchange rate
between Singapore dollars and Malaysian
Ringgit
we've just opened an office in Thailand
which in the course of the next few
months will be rolling out the product
into Thailand so now I'm going to need
to have the exchange rate from of the
price of gold in Malaysian Ringgit and
in Thai Baht this is designed to allow
me to put in the two pieces of
information from two different sources
right from the fellow who who's checking
up the international exchange rates and
the fellow who is putting in the gold
prices right so I have gone so the first
the first two lines gold source of cash
source these are the people that I'm
going to authorised put in those
transactions because I don't want you
putting in the fact that gold is $1 a
kilo and they put me buying gold
right I mean I know I mean that that's
me and similarly for the person putting
in the exchange rates we don't want you
putting in that there are you know that
one Malaysian Ringgit
is worth 5,000 Singapore dollars that
would have the same effect you get cheap
gold right um
so okay so I'm gonna have because there
are multiple currencies I use a mapping
now a mapping isn't associated array you
know what they are right so I can use
like my R for malaysian ringgit to give
me one value in the array right other
terms are an associative array and the
same thing would be cash ready which we
see I'm simply using to say that that
value has actually been set and is valid
because I don't want you trying to do a
transaction with a currency that hasn't
been set I could have done structures
but
I didn't okay so when we created it we
had the constructor I passed in gold
sauce underscore cash sauce underscore
which I put into those two values
because I did that you can click on the
blue buttons and see those values we've
got a function called set gold price
which is a public function anybody can
call it which doesn't sound right
because I just said only the gold sauce
can call it right but the second line
says require message sender equals gold
is equal to the gold source so if
anybody else does call it the second
line will cause that transaction to
revert meaning it will stop execution
any changes that you might have made
which in this case will be unwell
if you get past that hurdle you set the
gold price and you set the flag saying
that that the gold price is now valid
because I don't want anybody calling the
contract until both the gold price is
valid and their currency exchange rate
is valid for the cash rate
well the the center has to be the cash
sauce same thing right the gold person
can't set the cash price they cash
exchange rate and I said I set the rate
which would be for malaysian ringgit
about three alright so i make entry
number the entry of my are in there to
the three and i said cash ready to true
which means now you can talk you can get
a malaysian ringing exchange rate
and then we have the function to get the
cold gold price now this one's a little
bit different it says public anybody can
call it it is view now a view means it
accesses state variables but it does not
change anything so it's a constant
function now a constant function as I
mentioned earlier you can call it from
any node in the network you do not need
to communicate anything to any other
node in the network to know that you
call it therefore it's a free call
it's still hot
these are amazing
made in Malaysia lovely coffee okay
right so here if cash ready currency
return right now what does that actually
do well it does is is the bit you can't
see which is the right hand side it
returns the price and okay flank the
price is before before you change it
it's initialized to 0
the okay flag is initialized to false so
become so if the cap if you have never
initialized the exchange rate it just
returns which means it will return with
okay being false if the gold is not
ready it will also return so okay will
be false otherwise price equals cash
rates times currency divided by one even
but how am I talking about in there
well obviously yet the bit where you
multiply the cash rate by the currency
right by the gold price so three
Malaysian Ringgit times 50 Singapore
that's right three bring it to the Singh
dollar times fifty Singh dollars to a
gram I can give you a hundred and fifty
bring it to a gram what is the / one
ether
no it wasn't a rhetorical question what
is the one if they're doing that
Oh nope nope nope
anybody know the exchange rate from from
malaysian ringgit to Singapore dollars
so I can you shout that one out that
sounded good three-point what
two point seventy two point nine eight
three point zero seven yeah Bobby it
stays that it's got decimal points in
there somewhere right what is the price
of gold one gram of gold is Singapore
dollars no idea it's put in ayan like it
used to be about fifty point three to
seven o'clock we got decimal places in
there hungry guys how do we represent
numbers in aetherium because both
numbers are multiplied by 10 to the 18
right so if it's 50 dollars the actual
number there's 50 times 10 to the 18 the
exchange rate is 3 times 10 to the 18 so
if you multiply two numbers both of
which to the whole number multiplied by
10 to the 18 you can I have to divide by
10 to the 18 to normalize it back to a
number with 18 decimal places
yes no maybe right because if I put
hundred to represent one so I want to
put one point one it's a hundred times a
hundred which is one with four zeros
after it so I have to take off two zeros
afterwards to make it equal back to
equal one wouldn't ya bingo so that's
why I'm dividing by one Aoife and at the
end of that I say okay equals true so
that when I return we know it's valid
does that work for you cool no
because one ether is one ether is one
followed by 18 decimal places
yeah sorry said one ether is or one
ether is just like everything else it's
one with 18 decimal places so it's just
a convenient way of saying well and
followed by 18 zeroes okay so there we
go
I have a function that gets the gold
price and if we are incredibly lucky it
might work it ought to work it worked
when I was sitting in the car parked
waiting for Saul to get back to his
hotel because he'd been off the
sightseeing
oh by the way sorry I did I introduced
stool at the back so is my colleague
from hello gold now now go look at it
but can you please all join me and say
just one thing dissolve happy birthdays
all thank you
right okay good right so we've done that
we've done that ah what's the gold price
for the type I'll be done type out
what's the gold price to tie box let's
have a look
T
H B first the quotes get the gold price
s okay is it because I never said the I
never actually upset anything for the
minute okay
so let's set some values here and I'm
going to be incredibly lazy we're going
to chip we're going to choose those
things that I really went up with so the
gold price is going to be 50 followed by
18 zeros which I always do is 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 put
in the quotes because it's a big number
and for some reason they like big
numbers in quotes take out all the
spaces
yeah last one and what's the gold price
at the moment gold price is zero set the
gold price and it says you've got all of
this all of this
hang on somewhere on the left-hand side
look at it in a minute it's it kind of
it kind of succeeded but you can prove
it succeeded because you can check the
gold price right
till now I've set the gold price in this
thing and every single nose on the
ethereal Network if this was a live
contract would know that the gold price
is 50 and I could set the exchange rate
for Malaysian Ringgit as my double quote
there 2 3 also followed by 18 digits 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
followed by its quote we call set cash
rate for Malaysian Ringgit and what did
it say it said I did something wrong ah
and the reason it is something wrong was
I sent it from the wrong from the wrong
account because up here are the accounts
I sleep I consent from I need to be
sending from the cash sauce which is the
one with four being which is there so it
says here that the transaction failed if
I try to send exactly the same
transaction from that account if I'm
very lucky you said it succeeded and
[Music]
if I ask it for the time-bar price it
will say failed if I ask it for the
Malaysian Ringgit price if I am
incredibly lucky it will tell me the
price is fifteen
bring it hundred and fifty bring it
round of gold right now that is an
insanely simple example and that would
be just a very small part of a big hole
that you put together
sorry zoom which bit
the rock this side
zoomy yeah okay why not
oh yeah
come on
decided that you wanted
so in the sermon is a possum eyes do you
think that plus or minus doesn't I think
no I doubt it that's just it does I
would do that you have the wrong side
what I do love you you just making sure
he knows that it's okay gets do that
comes back yes
take that back up and forget it let's
just do that yeah there you go
is that okay unfortunately they don't
make these draggable so we have looks in
here using some of the principal things
that are important
the first one is controlling permissions
by the address from which the
transaction is sent
[Music]
the second one is the various data types
including the associative array right is
basically it's a sparse array
you've got max you've got max in
JavaScript how many it's the same thing
right
[Music]
success
there are any questions at this point I
think a few people are still playing
with it the great thing about this
environment is it's just like jsfiddle
you can change something you can you can
see the results instantly
one thing that one thing I've noticed is
a lot of people only make what is
absolutely necessary public I tend to
make everything possible public because
it because you never know when you're
gonna have to debug something right you
can always work out what the variable
should be so there's no point hiding it
just make it public so that's there and
you can see it clearly
all right so how are we doing with that
is everybody happy
so what exactly the difference there why
would anybody you put something as my
missiles Wow you put functions private
it's very essential to the function
private the moment you put something on
the on the network which holds data
which is important the holds ether you
have to have private functions otherwise
people you get in there and they get
inside yes in my view is not terribly
necessary unless you're absolutely
confident everything works well if you
are if you know if you've got something
to fully debug for everything else yeah
you can set things to private just
because it makes the interface clearer
yeah because you can see on the right
hand side I've got everything listed
there you don't want it classify rubbish
with 500 different variables
okay so are we ready to move on from
there
Ramon should be nervous just know it's
up to him okay it's doing something so
do you have any other questions at this
point
we do get a special special plane and
more
okay pick toasts obviously at this point
I've got something we could Mickey Mouse
right and you say well why would I do it
on a centralized server the first thing
is my or my systems Republic in the
orders of all and I want to have as I
say the different actors who don't I
don't need to give them special access
to a particular server they can all
interact directly with their own local
nodes but it gives them gives them
access to the contracting so the one was
when you want massive adoption you don't
want people having client or you can
have a web client but the web client can
talk directly to the net without even
having a back end which is where web 3js
comes in and that is like with web a
very brief heads up on it before we
start web 3j s is a way to do all of
your interaction including signing of
transactions inside your browser right
and the only time it leaves your browser
is as a science transaction and it goes
it goes either into your local goes on
your machine or through an HTTP but it
just puts the site transaction into the
transaction right
now I'm quite sure that you have heard
like for example about yeah I see it the
ICO initial coin offerings the ways that
one of the ways that startups are
raising huge amounts of money to you
know to develop products with that is
done on the blockchain people send ether
to the contract they get something
called a token the token is just a value
in an associative array basically with
function to allow you to transfer those
tokens back so you could sell your
tokens and stuff
yeah how're you doing Ramon I think it's
helping people so he doesn't have to
come up and do the next can contact me
up okay now here's the fun bit yes can
you update a couple contract once it has
been launched from what I've said so far
what do you think the answer is no kind
of no you can replace them at least you
can't replace it you can put in another
one so if I have this contract with a
pointer to the contract I'm supposed to
use so the first contract becomes like
the portal you can then change the
second-level contracts I can make it so
that a contract can be stopped from
working altogether one of the things up
there is self-destruct I can actually
remove a contract from the blockchain
completely by issuing a self-destruct
functionally but I cannot change
anything that has been written onto the
blockchain which makes the company who
put name email address and other
information of their clients onto the
blockchain as they registered them in
plain text rather irresponsible because
that information is going to be there
forever
yeah so you can have you can upgrade
contracts if you build it in but you
have to design it because the old
contract will always be there so if you
were to look for example okay if you
have a contract where somebody made a
mistake at sending wrong information to
it it's always there so
[Music]
because I haven't put any beer to me but
if I had put an event in there you call
an event it looks like a function but
it's the instead of saying function says
events when you call that the only thing
it does is write a log that gets stored
with the transaction call if the
transaction succeeds
you can have code written in Java
machine then if you do that is in that
time
right information point I'm going to
leave it because I think if you think
there's something interesting you might
stop taking the Jaime as with everything
else
right and then she doesn't write
information this is dango right no yeah
hey guys Dan support everyone's forming
having success certain level of success
failure
who's compiled everything and everything
works for them okay okay who's having a
problems with I think creating a
contract or setting values always
confused about they how okay disclaimer
like everything's here is very confusing
when I was throwing myself as it was
like super confusing
it's okay to be confused so just like
you know raise your hand and ask
questions either Oh Krishna are
I think there was the kind of just need
to address yeah you just need to
addresses because the constructor
functions it takes two addresses you
want a dress that was able to set these
cool value than an elevation from you
okay so the question is what was the
addresses mean so like what is he room
will change there are like yeah your
addresses like the public address the
tax code it's like a second house or a
public key and basically you have a
private key that controls verify that
you signed this certain transaction a
certain attraction of watching by
looking at your public key right so and
the the address can either mean like a
private individual basically sort of but
you can you have a private key to this
address and you can just find
transactions like you would a sense of
if their right to another address or to
another and context also to have the
same public practices right one of us
yeah it's not any kind of superspeeding
new it's a unique address that responds
to like a private key so you able to
train your own private key
yeah if you lose the private key lose
access to your to your public key
biscayne you cannot move your funds
sorry you had a question you had a
comments okay confusing not confusing
what should be explained better yeah
pair of keys is basically they can
account when you're in rumors about
people losing like ton of money on
Bitcoin or something that actually means
that this value is filled the air and of
all chains recording there but it's it's
you know like it's a streaming it to a
public that someone lost a private keys
to so they cannot like move this ether
or Bitcoin out does it make sense yeah
sort of like Lisa Connors is a user but
you can generate the infinite number of
I think located a number of key pairs
all right not necessarily that you can
create an Italian fascism it's just like
a munching so you so the question is
like for each contract you generate
errors so like when you when you publish
a contract to a chain whether it's your
own local Cheney or whether it's
actually named this area network the
cactus is being generated for you by the
by hole denotes I don't remember exactly
it was supposed to process some quick
generating this mattress but I think
it's based on the time and the block
number and amounts of that block in
which the contract is being it's unique
it's saying there is like I'm not a
cryptographer sciences scientist but
it's like the probability of collision
of mattresses is like tending to zero
like it's pretty impossible
yeah question of support
shall we go into technical questions
yeah I've got a few persons I have
what's a hat okay question how's it
coming back
oh okay like what do you plan to do now
is they basically ask questions I'm
gonna run
that's right now and then I'm gonna do a
bit more hands-on work and try to link
it to our experience with JavaScript and
node that's how good idea okay
real world of things that people are
actually doing with something so like
that's that's gonna somewhat a tricky
part the most popular thing that
everyone's crazy about is like icos is
basically raising a ton of money I'm
actually a bit bored by that like that
topic so that's that's one way like you
see in the talking
another good use case would be cryptic
it ease like burning in these cases when
you have a like multi-party marketplace
right where participants that in
marketplace they're not necessarily
trust the intermediary so for example
like if you were playing online poker
so for example if you're playing online
poker right and I got a poker player but
so you playing online poker
and you kind of you go to this website
and you're not necessarily like you
might think like okay this website is
their business that that probably they
might have certain business incentive to
have their back-end logic playing in
their favor right so like you you pick
your cards and you think like okay what
if they the order of the business
modified their backing code to have some
certain like smarten AI that will
perform certain logic that there's no
way or like very low chances of you
winning right time it doesn't make sense
okay and with watching what he can do is
you can basically have this
Becca logic II publish it to the network
and when people interact with with those
contracts like anyone can review the
actual source code of what's going on
behind the scenes and you can exactly
see like exactly part of it is that you
actually interact with a real life right
if you have a one build like a stripe or
a right to intubation or anything about
this razor has higher part we've moved
on with money great so the exciting part
with with the theorem and will change
it's like there's no API it's like baked
in silly yeah
does it make sense so far so basically
anyone can go even with ether scan or
other methods go into contract address
and see the exact source code of that of
that contract and you're able to like
decide for itself whether this code is
doing something shady or whether it's
being a legitimate code and just being
like assigning rewards in a just manner
to all the participants right so like
that's just for example if white cryptic
eighties was like such it um doesn't
know why it was like a hit but the the
way words is that you can kind of buy
and sell those cats and you can be
assured that like the order of this game
is not exactly like money bleeding and
creating duplicates it's the sole story
the verifiable of all chanting to see
all transactions apology
okay that's okay
what kind of IP then anybody anybody
anybody can take it very simple you got
it but once you if it's gonna really go
you can have offline parts of it but
anything you put on the blockchain is
public and okay so you wanted real-world
cases first one give it give everyone
okay hello gold we actually had a token
sale we've made my name pop up as a
result of that we supported a number of
people in the community who we felt
we're doing good work and in the
etherium community there are a lot of
people doing good work one of them is
give it giveth have designed a framework
for people for charities to raise money
and for they raise money people
contribute in the form of ether but they
have to lock in goes according to
according to a road map as they achieve
the goals along those road maps funds
get released to them the UNHCR I've got
a private etherium Network which they
use to channel funds to refugees and
refugee camps so yeah I mean you know if
they end up talking to their banks at
both sites but they they target the
right person they integrate the
blockchain technology with iris scanners
so a refugee in the camp can go
into designated stores in the camp take
the goods he wants he scans his iris and
it registers with the blockchain he has
received a certain amount of funds to
pay for those groups
aetherium yeah but you know most what we
talk about be the public aetherium
network JPMorgan has created a version
of the theorem called quorum which has a
level of privacy built-in and that they
are proposing to the enterprise etherium
alliances one of the technologies for
interbank record passing fund transfers
and stuff like that until there is a
very large very active alliance was
includes many major banks were
interested in using etherium as part of
their structure because obviously you
know you said to him you get information
from him and all of that favor yeah
settlements yet and it multi-source
people who don't necessarily trust each
other all protected by private keys yeah
so if you enter fine and financial the
other big financial staff banking and
stuff they are you know like in the past
they looked at other blockchain
technology now that theorem seems to be
the
good choice cerebellar patient-specific
so if you're doing a bank we're trading
on these things it does depend right
we're nowhere near the right brakes at
the moment but you have to understand
aetherium is what four years old and it
has got some of the brightest minds in
the business working on it they're there
they're working on Sharlee and don't
know what else to do to get the rates up
I mean do the first target is be able to
match reason we're nowhere near it but
how much is it right now it's like it's
quite as like sometimes you're not
seventh know but I'm gonna yeah it is
yeah I still quite is still quite slow I
mean you know a few thousand today but
yeah
I think I'm wrong it's no isn't one of
those way more than that because I mean
you can get you can get 300 in the block
now I seriously can't remember this
please is always going up draymond Green
but yeah 700 mm transition cookie okay
so it's like 1514 800 everybody over a
thousand certainly yes in its infancy
but there are lots of technologies being
evaluated to increase that the first one
is he was getting rid of getting really
the proof of what mining which will
which will speed everything up and then
sharding various other things i Sakhalin
i sat in a room with a metallic mushroom
talking about all of these technologies
that he anything that he had on the road
mapping I'm just with one word intent
yeah mystically right so yeah they're
you know smart guys are out there
they're working on it and they have you
know they have these numbers in their
sights
okay are you ready or do you guys want
to do a tea break or relax for a second
because we're gonna go intense with a
lot of more confusing stuff perhaps 15
minutes break 10 minutes break and we
can make something go ask more questions
I want to get a better sense of like of
the room what are the questions what's
confusing what's not so yeah please ask
questions speak out maybe we should like
to make a few steps back and explain
some poor things before we go into like
more harder coordinates
yeah do 10 minutes and be it's like 15
15 or mine on the clock like all gonna
be jumping all over the place and giving
like examples that lead to right so like
when people were asking like whether
contracts can be seen by anyone it's
like this is like an example of cryptic
eighties one of their contracts right
and someone else was asking about
like whether like what happens when I
screw up a contract and like how do you
redeploy it so like the answer is like
you cannot be employed once you deploy
the contract it's there forever it's
gonna have this oh it's sort of there
forever unless you're self destructive
which still kind of remain so what's
more advanced already like you can stuff
to stock the contract which will make it
inactive but it's still really kind of
later you're part of the bull chain so
someone asked about what happens like
what to do if you have a complex
contract and you want to kind of
minimize the risks of making a bug there
and you will make up up there and it
might be varied interests like what
people do is they will explain a one
large project into sub contracts and
likes smaller apps and then deploy them
independently and they would probably
have like have a master master contract
that will link to other smaller
contracts is that right Dave if you can
if you can said so here's they also get
your code or digit this is one of those
important things if there's any value of
what you're doing yeah if you're really
dealing with like real money and like
for example if the kids are doing with
just no money here but it's like twenty
thousand dollars today and like quite a
lot of tokens but basically you split it
into smaller contracts and anyone can
yeah security is very important so if
you're doing something off like real
value and dealing with the real money
and you like advertise it to people and
you want people to send you there or
playing with your game or do something
like make sure your contract is being
audited by like people who have done it
before you know what they're doing and
that make it what is it again
again and maybe you will be securing
[Music]
yeah this is pretty quick I said so like
for example when we talk about that
complex our company project very popular
and people use it to like look at
transactions and discover what things
are going on on the blockchain ok Syrian
watching specifically there is a
different poaching Explorer or like
other shades from an era or Bitcoin etc
and yeah you can basically see all
transactions that happened to this
contract
so like this culture has an address
right and you can see all the like
pending transactions that are happening
right now frog where they usually do it
if they have if they're sending any
value so I made you think thing when you
see that contracts are having that zero
user sorry there's actually science your
research it means that probably someone
is calling a function or but it's having
a function it's they're not transferring
the value they just like like maybe
setting a certain value to it within the
contract so it can be kind of cryptic
ease and copy copy basically
and do you know that someone asked about
licensing Simon asked about rice and
said right
or someone else asked about what happens
to your property rights okay code right
so I heard especially than other dude if
it does like we have work for a serious
you'd like
well probably you could license it buddy
you'll probably impossible to enforce it
like that it's like your private a
license but I don't think it's even
possible to enforce it because it's all
open in a while if theorem clients
themselves there were several major
clients that brought a real nose is like
death there is a private parts client
those would mean most of the ones they
are under GPL license and one of them is
under less forgiving lessons so yep you
can call me it's the qualitative it's
pretty complicated
okay um
another thing that we probably did not
go into detail is I do support to
understand that there are different
types of networks right it's like what
you guys had in women's right I think
that's cost like a bit of a confusion
it's so important to understand so we
have here a link environments at Thomas
Cooper TM right that means it's like a
virtual machine of etherium that runs
within your browser within this
roommates right and there are other
networks there is like life etherion
effort which were like if you go to a
point market cap quite a market bad
that's where you will see the value in
price that's that's kind of value
derived from make the real effort and
that's what you see in it does man there
are like other networks that we're like
actions do not cost money
like there is a raphson and they keep
them off your own node on a real
ethereal network because actually saved
a lot of time because they get mind and
they cost actual real money if you're
running again the Neo VM it's it's free
and it's a paradise okay what shall we
do shall we go and like step by step
explain this contract a little bit yeah
race hands up if you want to get more
understanding of what this means we're
we're doing here as soon as humans
the bottom one zone
okay
do you guys want to yes and possibly to
see that what I wanted to do the main
thing that I was prepared to do is like
link what you've seen so far
it relates with more like day-by-day
coding experience that it would probably
have expect because you know no one not
me guys probably coding your JavaScript
in your job in you know but base 19
right what do you do is you use you know
someone sex and they're required a set
of tools that will help you actually you
know have a your contracted get and
compile it and be able to deploy it to
the test networks to a local network and
[Music]
to production network as well right so
let me go
someone's asking questions sir no
missions all right I'll do it it's
pretty fun traduction around what tools
are on there outside over two minutes
and again bringing some like ID where
you did just I play arrow see me already
hear me okay excellent where you can
just play with contracts that like fully
data really quickly deploy there within
your local yeah within your browser but
it's pretty limited so what do you want
to do is you want to do several things
first you want to rock a local note
there is this thing called test our PC
which is basically a local node that
will be right on your arrow to this on
your
machine you can just do this by npm
install' test a PC
No
okay if they're in the narrow I see this
button copy paste this and
worse
okay so I know you might get confusing
there are several again there are
several types of networks right so
there's the main net where the actual
real stuff is happening under or you can
have there's like three public task
networks and you can run your local
network which is basically one node that
is not going to be really connected to
the Internet and it's really really fast
right so you leave it to like test your
contracts really quickly so you can
install this but I'll going to show you
a bit more interactive because you know
if you're on test are these questions
questions questions
No
it's a well
on Instagram on telegram what about
can you ask the question or is there a
question can you also explain
orchestrating actually can you explain
if this could be used for this reading
there actually changes what do you mean
but which have changes
right
if the example that we used can actually
talk history religion is sort of yet you
can secure enough if you have enough if
you have a source of exchange rates that
everyone in the network every state
prostitute yeah you can you can
basically use that
but in the reason there will be
reasonable to say that the contract is
basically like a stateful service they
don't need to run on any server adjust
to the blockchain to
and their questions yeah that's exactly
that's the fact that every single
transaction of recording yeah so like
it's absolutely right except yeah and
it's everything is public everything's
recorded everything is you're messing
around you're near testing things you
get to a certain point we think heck how
do I end up with those values
well um right with a blockchain you can
replay everything to find out okay so
everyone installs
I mean tester PC is one example and
another one something I'm talking about
like running a local node this is
looking to be a preparation for us doing
a bit more complex stuff another one is
you can actually if you go to a truffle
framework we call the base name - this
is a bit like visual like it's basically
one thing it runs a tester piece you
know and just like as some UI you might
um I know when I use it but it's just
like I want to use it right now on this
workshop because it's a bit more visual
and you can like see what's going on in
a more entertaining fashion rather than
just looking at boring logs like this
because what you see right now is the
same thing as here so
[Music]
so again this is like a test test
environment that that is just like
useful intended to use them I use the
administration so you remember in remix
when you were asked we should be put in
accounts right
those are like test accounts with Conway
ether in them is just like a for testing
purposes right unreal Network real if
your network no one's really gonna give
you 100 ether for free unless you want
to pay like okay but on your own one
node kind of network you can't do
whatever you want so basically again
they have all these accounts data set
mining is happening automatically we
have blocks right now we have a theorem
books that are mined transactions your
transactions and this thing is running
on your like local server
RPC server okay so I'm gonna be jumping
different topics so we covered briefly
so this is running like everyone's is
filing this their own got access to
ganache right everyone still dead I hope
it's right now so it's pretty useful
when you're developing another thing is
like one thing that we didn't mention is
meet a mask
Madame s very important piece of
software it's actually a home plug in
huh what is this Oh Minnie Mouse Mateo
so what this thing does is basically I
think there are several theorem in the
old browsers out there one of them is
brave there is a mint mask I think there
was my farewell that they have a chrome
chrome session as well so when you
install it it creates this extension and
it kind of serves as like you able to
sign some sections on different networks
with this extension so for example if I
go to you theory of maintenance so right
now I have a certain I don't have any
either
I think money grows in annual discipline
so for mine so I have some this is like
actual ether only mean that if I want to
send to someone and there are different
everyone's a star we can ask right okay
yeah okay so there's actually actionable
thing if you have a national Tehran is a
stolen and if you have a statistical
you're actually able to connect to your
local local test RBC environment
and I have how many sir
so
so okay service here's a good example
that mean actually sends some user phone
what visit into this account
how come to me this microphone fixed it
all wants to okay
so fantastic wonderful okay so if it's
confusing raise your hands and ask
questions so just getting ready an
example you know it's having so I'm
gonna use have already imported a you
can ask and I want to send some you
Pharaoh from for this account to
discount
send the men of our recipient a mammoth
that's antenna 30 next so this is
actually a signing process you will you
forget me doing if you're in development
going to see in this quite a lot if you
were interacting real chain that's going
you can see this quite a lot so you can
see like this summer it was actually
this is like final and irreversible but
we were on private network we just
connected to to this to be nice and you
guys admit protection fail I think it go
because hitting this didn't I do not
guess
you see in a dress
next
gas price
I suppose Dino gasps sitting it
anything
right now
oh yeah that one
yeah what a fight
no no no it's running on
I was about to give a nice example
No
[Music]
in this polimedia
why this day
the Emerald does not have the correct
nonce
you know why might not be working
well you connection sir I love cold
another user to look from though you
didn't know you could
No
by 7:00
the only problem is getting an option
he's gonna take it
attraction
amount of
[Music]
the youngest
anyway I'm sending over
incoming okay Oh actually I thought it
was a mean rhasta now I have some ether
okay I changed to another gentleman
effort which is like the public public
test test network called Roxanne and I
can send some ether okay this one
different is Easter
yes
Oh Spence Ahmed's success okay that's
good spending at least
so okay I mean maybe it was confusing
that I'm using Ralston just like one of
the tech networks out there it's out
there to test you can actually get like
[Music]
ether is not worth anything really but
you can just let me example of me
spending some value between two
addresses from one address to another
that is like signed by me to mess on the
alternate on the adults okay so okay we
have a ganache installed we have Newton
s pistol I hope there is kind of more of
us you guys understanding something
already too low at certain point there
and I don't think that I wanted to use
it to is I started trouble so truffle is
is the framework that does all the
containers where it's not around
chuckle does all the compilation and
like managing and testing contracts for
you you're honest everyone's good runs
good I want to see you guys have
questions promise I don't
good now next one in Boston um okay with
Whittier winter run ganache you don't
see like test RPC server you copy this
you open me to mask I need to customer
be see you at RPC URL and don't forget
that one two seven zero zero one is
different from localhost if you're
running into this issue that's probably
like it's the only network as compact as
we're different
but I had this or Italian stickers
okay everyone see this
success is interested in you too busy
cemetery
ha well you're running can I assure you
running like the tester if you see
something huh yeah see you will see it
right here you need to you need to
launch it and you will see which board
is it running on but I think you call
those different telegrams people will
get confused are you guys succeeding in
this arrow succeeding in this home you
will get Christmas wishes everyone's
running problems who is confused got a
problem or something yes
so
oh okay so you know things like you need
to import account like if you just
connected a private key and you can go
in to get out this is the key thing
Chucky's so this you're breaking sorry
there was this confusion like you didn't
you like way to just store a veto mask
you don't have any you don't have any
accounts like this I have a talk right
what are you doing is you do like import
account and you have an option either JS
file Oh private key and you can go to
ganache you do show keys you know what
have a key
and then you copy that key and paste it
in and Colombian account something if I
connected back to my environment I'm a
zero it immediately shows that have
hungry either
doesn't make sense
guys in the back are you guys how are
you like everything's player questions
okay something's up thumbs down okay
I'll get no no no someone's having a
problem what could it be otherwise
yeah
no no like this okay
so this is right
you have to say that
make sure yeah I know there's like very
important the security thing guys make
sure like if you you're gonna have a
crate right now I look like
private-public eat pears and the ones
that are trying to scream like do not
ever use them in production because if
you use them into production and someone
says you really for there it's gonna be
stolen work like be careful with that
[Music]
I'll get there yes
how do you don't get out you just go to
Daisy
in your office if you see
and
hello I've got a lot of you guys went to
Nika nosh hub is go to ganache the
truffle for style-conscious yeah we just
don't those yeah where I'm with this
okay
yeah and over there is more about gas
and
you know more about us and best price
right so so Oh
all transactions if you're setting a
certain stage value in your contract or
chain they cause gas gas is like of
arrival that costs either also also in
support to understand that like ether is
not the lowest denomination of value on
if you remember chain like the lowest -
away and gas it's like it has a variety
of way so gas price like one gas was the
unit average there is no gas station
website that actual toes here like they
forgot price on your ribbon area network
and usually like one gas costs I think
five ways of s Davis different gas price
you go in I think of it come on yes yeah
so these are the gases like a varietal
thing in your local environment you can
set like gas price to to whatever
arbitrary number you can set but in real
production network you just go to the
you know Google and it will tell you the
real time gas price and the reason why
gas price is important if you if you use
like Mickey Mouse see here when I was
sending introduction what is signing is
reflection right okay good
you said a gas price how much weight but
this is like only intestine we're living
and estimate you can run out of gas well
it's a kid intersection like the looks
of action it's not gonna go through it's
gonna get reverted and your gas gonna
get then it's not gonna get burnt but is
just gonna get converted as well okay so
far
Helene should we get further questions
questions questions intro speaker
Irma's 30 things if you go to official
website you also have a competition
about how much is one way okay so so we
get maintenance that back we played
around with with rivets and chocolate is
like the real deal it's like what what
you will actually be like Kim committee
excited say right just just for the
reference to resin on the framework bark
that's another alternative but I'm not
gonna go into it but it has sexy stuff
with IDF s a ton of other things
yeah but build a round with a bar it's
so basically what if what I'm talking
about right now I'm showing you the mark
and truffled those are like they're
building JavaScript but those they're
the frameworks so kind of like a you
know like you know like rails in Ruby on
Rails thing it's like that environment
and the set of tools that abstract
common things for you they basically
glue testing environment they glue mocha
to your tests so you can actually test
your solidity contracts in JavaScript
policy right and you can just run a few
functioning your console like I don't
know like let me give an example of some
other like things that I have I can do
truffle test and it's gonna deploy I'm
jumping forward a lot it's failed no
actually
yeah so Sammy didn't expert person so
those are the framework something for
your homework
daddy can explore them we can look into
trouble right now and again it's like a
set of tools to help you test the boy
keep track of contracts when you come at
them and you professional yeah so I hope
by now everyone's got trouble it's all
ok bye Cody thing's not gonna work came
from me now about that were confused
[Music]
- I didn't ask - did that question that
Oxford how good it was this did that get
Oxford is that clear now
I got no on the small opening I assume
science gate sounds yesterday's good
ha
yeah good question I wish
like how do I achieve all I'm gonna take
forever
do you guys want to do like a contract
from scratch the principle or they want
to continue as with already a different
button can be okay I will try to do a
contract from scratch
so the okay he just made some great a
new directory
jazz conf
just get ya
no one can see my career and I'm doing
trouble in it
ooh oh
[Music]
truffle in it so I got down why is this
my spring for some reasons so the weird
thing about truffle I'm not sure why
they haven't fixed it when he did
trouble in it it creates any project in
your current directory it does not
create a new directory so you need to
create a directory first but just on a
salinity CD into that directory ad pad
and only there do you top that I have no
business I missing something because it
doesn't mean okay okay basis someone
help I Drive a hairdresser
and then neighbors gonna copy out
shoes yeah okay cool so just grate the
chocolate at what it did you can see
here anything cool you can see a few
things contracts migrations test topic
on take a couple GS right and if you
allow me I'll just use some line Alexa
will so playing we say you cancel
contracts tests no tests
Michael is it safe for me to play with
the resolution
and the church
okay so what do you ready run total in
it it will create a basic structural
Raven contracts is where he actually
keep your submitted projects migrations
is where you it's like that stick files
that deploy your contract to the network
might be local network it might be a
public network it might be test network
so they are pretty important and because
you probably are just going to be
evolving over time it's important to I
think it's dinner it's like cold in the
dark but I'm gonna be losing this game
so um okay I will try to like beta fold
increase like this migration contract
which I kinda like should I use it
how embarrassing which helps you keep
track of your memories on the actual
team that's doing
I change it to keep work you know if you
notice quite a bit in their cookies
you don't still have a problem okay
I hope it's time overly or is it overly
complex but what about what's the
contract that I would try to write all
this write a game how much time it could
become an hour will probably be
sufficient as well it's a game where
cycle multiplayer game where everyone
can vote on a number between one two
hundred and whoever gets it closes to
like 30 percent of an average value wins
after either right does it make sense so
it's a beauty contest so everybody have
to guess what heroine house will pick
rate is their brain so err Lulu's from 0
to 100 and and whoever yes and number of
basis to the food is personal to the
average wins
okay so a great contract solidity
Oh get his first okay
well great has a configuration just in
case like
okay so we have to to migrations
we want to be doing tests for now I mean
it's it's really pretty good to do them
I probably should show them somehow to
you but I know this and I'm going to be
focusing on another contract that I have
an admission so I'm gonna cheating a
little bit but help it over pretty easy
to follow for this
come again
[Music]
like is it any better a bit more
demanding sir is that any better I'll
send you my country you know my my
probably address you can send you some
user site Emily why do you 31-point
video content we gonna do
trends gonna help
it's not gonna it's falling okay like
this
okay
so
and our race public force
what is this
okay so
usable
and you Oh sir
Oh
oh right
good idea I'll probably fail me there
was doing or not
[Music]
Chris Martin
it's hard enough to go to this base
right so
well basically we'll have a main
function like vote
actually
okay hello thinking oh dang a bit
getting into a bit more complex
Michael did you turn off an AC exiting
okay um I think I'm getting signals like
some doesn't think it's that simple it's
awful that I can show you guys
hmm
okay so I'm trying that's right if I
feel a little baby so what are you doing
okay so we becoming an owner the person
who created the contract in just in case
the security measure that you do in case
there are some value to contract and you
want to like just someone just rather
unattractive alligator's head back to
the owner
voting is basically will like let people
who at different accounts would and will
need a function that will like appendage
there is this tech convention used over
the underscore portal when arguments
just like easy to distinguish and
because you can load up on us we'll make
emails so much
Oh interesting thing like compared to
canister in I think Joe escape you just
like to make varietal declaration it's
going to be undefined insulating
everything is zeroed out
so like the value of some is is zero
it's different here by default the same
thing with if you have like a called the
corner and his value opener will be zero
who's going to be zero zero address okay
[Music]
come again paper o people of use that
the function can receive pumps okay
that's pretty important public means
that I'm not sure they were actually
gonna get in today people part but
basically what are you able to do is for
example if there were like money bolt
right and I could have another like
mapping of address value right I
couldn't I could do something like this
message value somewhere that's right
that will add add more sorry I'm nervous
doesn't make sense so this is going to
be a hexadecimal number off like for
example if if this participant of the
narcotic sentence calls this function
with an argument and with either value
this contracts got an executed some
logical set this internal Spade as
valium and they sign into the address of
the center that will also add more value
into the into the balances for that for
that Walter worth and we continue yeah
and
so we'll make sure that voters can order
the most
will will disregard the values for now I
just want to get a single spot so no one
gets confused sir I don't get these
[Music]
have you
what does it mean to hear how old she
has come 92
yeah oh yeah
okay so another important concept in
insulated is like you know in in
JavaScript or is inconsolable
it's literally there is like no
console.log there is this concept called
event and you have to make dafair the
brain and they can return the coma
specific data so I can do
and again those dogs are visible by
everyone
deductions certain transaction whatever
Annelle logs here
[Music]
how I did it any comments or shy
okay
but the first gots transactions
returning something
what
towards get UI and some
I mean I understand this conniving
variation of the previous game but I
hope it's more or less concise other
questions cast my code usage what is
that
sorry I don't know it tell me
looking we can just check whether any
comparisons
and you feel it
maybe I can copy/paste that real quickly
where was that a thing okay there were
sounds like that or something I have no
anyone with questionnaires
I'm sure I can't I just gonna need
something like my comfort zone tank yeah
it's already pretty bad it's like I want
to like avoid confusion like it's pretty
bad that you guys in confused it's gonna
be even worse about you don't know what
that I don't know what that piece are
french fries stay here so
and with a pair of leg they just paid to
the actual cycles they use or you
couldn't process with the people
function so that means that this
function can receive either yes yes so
first of eight it's like if you're
playing if you're buying something or
you're really betting on something you
can make actually have it over rival
that is like sets the price if they if
this can actually just like you ain't
no I'm not gonna use that you're in
price and it's like yeah yeah I mean I I
find it's pretty excited we go but if
you dig if you do that in like you know
in if you if you receive payments with
stripe or anything else like you have to
do enough like an authorization like you
know callbacks keys back and forth
between strata server and surety just
everything was bad
where's my expect cynical
[Music]
unexpected Smith
Oh after after all right thank you
III don't see pixels and setting goals
okay more of a success so that means
that a contract compiled okay and they
just think they may be a conference
compiled they get built and you get them
in in this case in this in this bill
directory and it's a constant important
part but I'm gonna make it jumping
things so then we cover quite a bit of
ground when contracts compile they
create this like Jason ABI advance and
they are pretty important so because
they basically contain your quite a bit
of information about it code they
contain all the interfaces about you
know all the functions so first up I
have a disability and it's gonna have
come on somewhere okay here we go it's
gonna have some information about the
actually be is a compound so long
ABI
thank you so into okay so in ABI this
actually kind of provides information
about your contract and function and you
can see that the name of the function is
vote a certain office that we just
declare
so we have a type of input type of
outputs
whether it's painful it's available and
so like the video of this thing it's not
really beautiful an interesting thing
about this is like function when you
when you build it deploy a contract you
were gonna receive this and also is
gonna contain somewhere like the actual
address where it's being deployed if it
is deployed this one is just composite
and deployed and you can build like e UI
based autonomic UI based on the API
array so it in fact when you when you
look at when you looked at or yeah at
the one we've been joined with example
with a change rates when you saw
contract here that like the they output
like the way you I was generated is
because thanks to that ABI G so far
so he's just basically generated based
on on this and we will need this later
if we'll good guess if you guys so what
happens I get will you come and
developed much yeah I know it's pretty
I'm Tina pretty boring right now have
think is really happening that much but
I just want to cover like different
stamps and stages the migration yeah
it's pretty common it's nothing to the
completion sorry for jumping things it's
just like a lot of different things
submitted cards if possible together
so basically when I went to compile when
I when I did a total compiled it
basically went through the code
investigating there were any like really
bad errors in it there are some warnings
and it generated what a combination
actually does is make generates a total
bytecode which you can see somewhere AVI
I mean
yeah I have a goat on a bike oh so this
is actually was being deployed on the
Honda rider local network or yeah that's
all the numbers that we saw earlier and
so I know this is pretty low level stuff
but it is pretty more than that sexually
I'm gonna I used to be st. John's for
twenty years and I never actually don't
like when in depth it off like you know
combination stuffing I was actually
excited so I know we haven't done much
yet but I just want to go through all
the steps and let's just publish this
contract with truffle to your hopefully
running test leprosy in mind actually
just like you I don't talk about that
service here promise that's pretty
so another thing slightly confusing
thing about truffle it has to and funk -
I do
Topol help
it has truffle migrate and truffle
deployed it's the same thing I used to
be so before I hit troubled employee so
we have this one track the help everyone
has it all and I have a sort of my
gracious at some kind of a migration
which basically takes the beautiful
country and the flora deployment there
was like way more that you could do here
a can i sat like for example with
example that Dave gave Obama changed you
can make add additional parameters for
would be shooted political track I found
out a little just give a decent if I do
chocolate deploy oh I think it's gonna
fail I know
okay no never specified not important
truffle content okay here you actually
specify how truffle like to each Network
people connected with doing deployment
okay Oh
it should be crazy boy I'll let the
removal so if this config file I think
connects operating this thing so I keep
it simple and not use any one because
they're all confused already
okay so cup chocolate yes right I wasn't
in there one or has it any confused
spaces yes problem this thing okay I'll
soon so I got a few guys know why
okay okay
I heard you okay fear Oh someone deleted
our thing okay
is it good oh sure okay cool
okay so basically what this thing does
it because we're running tests are we
seeing a freaking garage so we had this
server that runs and accessibility
support the services server and in
trouble we'll be connecting to this
environment any network
oh nice success exciting are you guys
excited okay
exciting thing okay you can actually see
stuff happen what just happened is
trouble went out and performed this
performed this to migrations it deployed
the default migration of contract
ignoring Finnell and the contract that
we just wrote it's like super simple
this dummy contract that doesn't do much
at all but basically deployed and it's
kind of important for you guys to get
started we can see some output here this
is actually the code like the public
address of that person is there in our
local in your local test every cent of
work I know you can see some changes
that happened in test RPC itself and you
know I'm using inrush again because it's
like UI so it's less confusing that just
like running with the same piece of code
in income online so what just happened
because tester pcs pretty fast it's like
one cuz I should probably right now we
usually it's like wonderful sources I
should go block and we can see like
contract creation contact call this this
is amendment immigrations contract and
this is the actual the actual
the actual contract that we that we just
developed in each context so this is
that okay okay follow me any questions
so far everyone's excited we deployed a
real contract a contract which one you
want to mention that I'm not sure what's
what's the goal is gonna date date huh
becomes you know why it's like me
Creator person that is being so Mike I
just avoid contact and then it says show
me make so yeah it's not a complication
I should say that's the hash of that's
the hash of the transaction as a cinema
this equation I think maybe having
trouble paying immigrations early
truffle police or excuse
oh it sends some they first created
migrations contract is the trouble thing
it's uh big confusing equated in this
migrations this migrations contracted
and it sends stateless of a to that
migrations contract that we performed
yet
but it was important for business so
this is the actual contract that we just
deployed this dispute thing and so okay
and experiment if we go into like beauty
contests EDIF Oh Jason front the vehicle
here is pretty much maybe the same so if
I they talk of business that's that's
the bytecode so it's exactly the same
and somewhere here will be the address
so this is the thing contract enemies
should this revision configure this and
you can see it here as well so it's the
same is the same thing I just off you or
the contract that you just deployed when
you open a Columbia and this is the
address that you're going to use
incorrectly this contract okay and okay
but show you next is this is a spear so
far
why do we do it this way okay so the
migrations contract keeps track of the
critters migrations that he dumped like
you in-depth explanation will be
provided by you can even use multiple
contracts in one and you can actually do
I think then and you know do miracles
here it was a second contract and
passing like so they contracted address
and you can actually took the sale and
coin yeah so like you basically can do I
don't know stuff like deploy deploy
migrations I don't know it's like a nice
let's not even migrations ABC whatever
just abstract ABCABC one
and you can make them interdependent
yeah like even if this contract depends
on the other contract you can
you could do something like this if like
to remember you guys someone asked about
like whether like what happens if the
Cody was strong and that's personally
initiating a contract and what is it
another one and sort of how you did and
if you can't get way more complex
workers but I'm just like I'm trying to
keep it simple questions questions
questions questions yes gentlemen Laura
yeah question I think it's like we're
moving a few steps forward so shall we
go into this right away shall we go to
this thing make a very good question I
said I think that's probably one of the
best one of the things which everybody
here has a direct application yeah okay
so okay I wanted to do a few things here
but I think that's a very good question
because we were running outside and
people ran out of patience so the quick
answer is there is this thing called web
three nice applause who's written in J's
yeah and that the mask is a web three
provider right so in your video code in
your web application basically you will
have a you'll be interacting with this
rival like web three viral this is oh
again I'll show you something like
JavaScript I decided to see how
struggling somebody activity I'm the
only person excited
okay so okay this is some JavaScript
code finally break I'm just jumping many
steps I hope it's a little more okay so
basically the rustling some magic here
web three is this library that you go
two or three there's amazing people form
a foundation
sadly none of them of this conference
maybe next time they were in Singapore
there Wow
[Music]
so this like take a library that
provides you connects your code your
JavaScript code in a browser to to
whatever net from the name connected to
image - okay I also did not yet okay so
I give a few ideas 2014 give a few fun
okay let me--just they try to summon
stuff here okay how to interact back to
the question how to interact with your
contract that you deployed so we have
this very thing and the important bit
you need to use like a few things you oh
you didn't make any uninstall they're
free agent you have installed travel
contract right and then from your
deployed so this is actually a bit more
I feel like the matura
who does the same thing it has like this
my beauty contest contract okay thank
you sir
I guess sir fantastic okay so remember
when we did deployment we got this we
got this contrasting data file
so this is the one that you also get in
keeping your front end project
repository and you will actually require
it your in your front end code right and
then it's you use your project start
your new contract like peach imagine
tour
deploy instance and then he basically
can interact with like vote and I can do
boat one from from one of the from the
main account it's that more like I know
I'm skipping some stuff but that does
that like more or less clear you're
getting like if you it's a piece of
story yeah okay okay
so that counts are coming from remember
when we were sitting up mask so well -
but I did sort of you're being one of
the first
if you're using Meza mosque as your
worth three provider in other words it
injects you a connection to the network
you can use the you end up using the
accounts in metal mask anytime you want
to submit a transaction however Mesa
Mass will pop up ask you to cite the
transaction so nothing happens without
you saying so right if you're running
parity of the parity know that the bank
and use the parity signer in exactly the
same way so the parity sign that will
come up and ask you to sign the
transaction yeah so okay so like here's
here's an example so okay sorry you
script the case but it's yeah I think
they did not pretty good job so cheers
to them so principal I a monkey needs
mouth spray and I am connected to ear
off syntax password
what meeting us does oh yeah it's cool
it's code okay so injects this like web
three huge success web three three
library and you can do ton of
interesting stuff here using media mask
sorry this is a trick right
and this thing they're like a huge new
conditioner out it and you interact with
it to do one of two like scientific
collections like using this library you
can like get your ether balance in your
in your account you can send
transactions you can call functions
that's like Oh gateway this yeah that
gave a drug to to motion develop a
solidity so you're gonna be interacting
a lot with it
right does that answer question Wallace
right so K an example with with Brooklyn
so so right now I'm connected to two
across the network and like me to mask
their code is you know calling about 3GS
and it figures out that it's a long
effort and you can connect to for
example to be in Africa is like oh right
you're on production Network and like
that's me that that's me sign in right
and for example time you can also
station I first make insurance you might
have different cuts on a component was
like whatever and a key okay and it kind
of authorizes me there but it sees that
I don't have any I don't have any keys
because I don't have any keys Allah on
this discount it's like a
it's nothing
it's just like a county that has no know
if I'd be first officially like my what
I'm like cool accounts it will like me
to mask will listen to changes some f3
and will actually pull information from
ball chain that are that was specific to
this and does it make sense more or less
is that acceptable shall we go in depth
on something arrows fear I can see your
faces okay
yes so I jumped question like topics
what would you guys into something shiny
more questions shall we make it my
contract has its own private like fun
yeah contract has its own balance in
storage the right of course there
exception but he can he can refuse you
money if it's a function fails exception
yeah
okay so contracts are addresses just
like any other address in that you could
accept that
contracts will only accept ether if you
explicitly allow them to accept either
so you saw the function the word payable
of that you never own the private keys
to a contract closer right you never own
the private keys to a contract so if
you've got either inside the contract
you have to have code in the contract to
send it out right in the contract in
this contract there is no method but in
the one you put up earlier there was no
method to withdraw that ether so all
that will happen is people will put
either into the contract and you can
never get it out again which is
dangerous which is you don't have that's
called trap to you yes like and no it's
the same thing as like lost keys so
you're not bar - you can't code you can
allow it to transfer you can have
focuses in there to transfer see exactly
help drive sales
yeah indeed certainly yeah you're gonna
have like something like this message
sender transfer and the number of value
you're like if I call this function okay
let's say I'm like just like super
simple super silly yeah just the girl
who pays the stranger like please
whoever's gonna call this function how
do you get how do you put either into
into it okay so you tell you you've got
your website written so like normally
you have a plugin for PayPal or
something like that right a bug in for
aetherium so your plugin for etherium
would normally be web through expected
web 3 enables our web front-end I'm
talking in your JavaScript on the site
so you build a plugin that uses
JavaScript which using web 3 enables ya
so in order to use it just like cryptic
is it would say you have to have a web 3
provider or most meta mask is one of the
one of the most common yeah right
right so then when you get there it will
know what your meta basket counties yeah
automatic you'll say okay this is your
account this is your balance and then I
want to buy five so it calculates how
much you have to pay and when you click
buy it will send the by transaction to
meta mask to sign and you'll see it
coming up in metamath saying I want to
send five ether to this address or three
ether to this address and you signing in
meta mas so that's your security so you
actually have to proceed let me do like
a super Shamus buggabugga John says
mythologize if you guys are going to be
very good thank you I want to do like a
while ago I went to do like super simple
the Nate button right this is just like
spike any jQuery code but it's very easy
to understand let me even like dump it
down so what was gonna happen I have
this so basically women when it click
where's my donate with man that spray
this thing goes in and I can make enter
one after that if I said okay I hit okay
mini mask comes in and I'm in a real
network right now and I just entered
that I want to send one ether to myself
right to to to whatever address it
provided a frankly I don't have
sufficient funds and then he tried to do
actually finally use a local network so
here how ton of phones how fantastic a
motive actually rescues a roster
I think this is a conventional thought
consider bringing these oh yeah okay let
me just make this really clear
oh come on connect okay they're also
network so if I a couple money here okay
I have some plunger
the name wound in mask enter one click
okay
signing with mini mask M'Lynn Austin
Network you sending one either to this
account from these account how the funds
okay all safe and secure they submit and
a transaction hopefully goes through
[Music]
yeah okay see the physician spending
right just now I confirmed them and take
myself on a test Network which is that
much but it's and the way it's being
accomplished it's like super single so
when three is coming like you don't have
two important in your content it's just
being injected but they need a mask
chrome session so like basically if I
don't have made a mask installed it's
gonna do nothing so it's the right now
what I've done it's it's not even going
to show the the name if I open this up
in in encoding ability
yes just doesn't show everything because
there was no momentum mascara signings
button so and when I'm going to click
the button its hits loading you get the
amount from prompt and then I convert
this amount to two way from you third
and I sent to this account right so this
is the they can where I want to send
money so this like that was super simple
thing this is the account that we see
the money this is a transaction and
receiving from this address this best
single questions so you're asking about
providers the only one that worked that
actually sorry okay the only provider
that actually the two providers that I
know of but work with accounts encrypted
in them are parity which is a lot more
or meta mask where meta masks USP is
basically the that they protect your
keys and they inject web 3 into pages
apart from that all you can ever do is
send ether however it is also possible
to write applications with web 3j s
where you handle the keys yourself
so one of the most popular sites in
etherium is my ether wallet now my the
wallet is completely JavaScript web 3j s
but they but you can use private key you
can use adjacent wallets which they will
link which they will then use the
appropriate functions to do the signing
with there or you can use something like
this which is a hardware wallet which is
if you have any either worth keeping you
should consider getting a hardware
wallet and then they communicate with
this using the relevant API to
communicate this and in these devices
your keys never leave the wallet right
the transaction goes in what goes in
through the serial cable it comes out
signed again so though there are plenty
of things with worth you know using web
3GS some of them do not need to use and
they sell you know to use another app to
contain the keys you can get the keys in
another way and of course it another
thing you can do with web 3j s if
there's something going on you can just
write things that monitor them they
don't need to always to send
transactions so you know what's the
state of a sale contract and you just
just extract the numbers then you don't
need any signing at all
yes okay there was a I think we were
like officially we are ending up to five
but we're happy to stay here as long as
you guys want and we can do more to an a
and maybe code warranty guys one's gonna
answer a few questions right in
[Music]
hmm t-shirts with questions yeah
yeah I'd like that I'm just making a
super dummy like state no code just
administrate how simple it can be to
just like receive or send pumps so
basically this is like so official I do
you specify to your destination address
first of your store your you have a
story he'll be more wallet and you
specify those two and then you specify
the value a few product and when this
function is being executed the one that
I sent in connections okay in in a
browser the again the mizzenmast
confirmation get up a lot and when
people click buy that means that
production is being signed and you get
the user and you get like there's
transaction verification sort of
information thing that you can make
everyone can see it never has access to
and you can see that it actually happens
so you can get actually to the
transaction you can make explore it you
can play around with my destination to
add rows you can see what happened here
you can go to to to my site and might
play around but there's actually make
you feel look at another food I made it
like super dummy simple so you just cuz
he did
at some time there was a having a
meeting code seriously even wanna
cookies that
[Music]
come again I say you're to paint the
ceiling
that'd be a transaction for his money
let's get that ring woman
but we agree with
everybody run yeah you can do that buddy
bowl kind of doesn't
[Music]
yeah you can do that and like I think
there are other volcanion projects
someone on facial management budget a
pretty well-known you can use it with
them and they specific sign for banks
yes this is a measure that Kiko Bank
nature specific design for thank you
fish with higher throughput their weight
faster than etherium they might be some
questions
yeah so actually yeah that's a very good
that's a very good thing so the cool
like really really cool thing about like
this went through provider what's my new
eyes messed up so what do you can do you
can actually make remember you had this
like spectra I don't know you can
actually used or web 3 provider and
injecting back 3 so now now remix is
connected to whatever network my mutant
mask is connected okay so if my medium
ass is connected to my local Takanashi
environment it'll basically be
interacting with ganache okay and so the
people thing what I can do is let me
connect it to directly thank you
okay and I can do some magic where's my
super complex
you know it's not that
okay so we have this remember we deploy
the contract over there I can okay
come on
did I spell it right probably didn't
know
I have no medium spelling is not my
forte
hold on I need me to keep it exactly the
same so what I can do is I call me paste
in my code and remember that we deployed
this contract and was sitting at this
address I can actually load it at this
address and it will compile again this
thing in the memory and provide some
lovely interfaces okay so I can
basically from remix I can interact with
my contracts that are on my local
machine basically I'm interacting with a
contract that is here and I can call
it's it's factions and if I call they
get an owner it will get the owner of
the contract which was said to this when
I was deploying it if I get me nothing's
gonna happen if I vote there's gonna be
a vote but because we were because I'm
not there was no function to retrieve
the load but it buddies but it happened
I knew it
and everyone can see that it's okay
there is even an event happened like
voted remember we had this wall string
so this has been most winning that's
event log screen
okay
okay sorry
okay so okay so Mysore walnut I know
this isn't easy
no but it gives it up no no no it's my
wallet pick up a contract pick up the
API the cony crayon whether that's going
to be interacting with your content
right okay
don't say okay coming in noise so
basically again
what do you are you following me when
you compile and deploy the contract you
receive this JSON object right you need
to require it as part of your front-end
absence like your JavaScript app you're
required and you have to help a few
other things like TOEFL contract web 3
which is like a sniper through private
so no likely that kind of provides us
like equate with the booking and then
you set like a cure provider which is
basically assigning assigning and like
giving access to a contract to the
approach environment as nice or around
the country it's like a wraparound
contract right and then when you use
your contracting that it's just like
your contract deployed and then you have
an instance and many cold actual
functions and more or less
if you're doing the function like if
you're calling the function that is
changing a stage in your contract yes it
will cause it will trigger this makes
mask signage pop-up window where you can
accept or reject to read data you do not
need to you don't need to sign and you
are nuanced the problem when you read
data the read coal is actually having
only on one on one note and it doesn't
cost any even right if you're having
certain function like vote because it
changes the this is these are these
stage where I always write if you change
any of this you will have to spend gas
I'm changing them if you are reading
them if you have like how about
functionally okay get my looked it's
just like bonus retrieves the go vote it
cause your meter and it doesn't require
any side
come again oh yeah
ha ha you can't today those weenie
you really like you connected to the
noon and there are millions of thousands
that you can bring down one load it's
not a problem
well yeah but the but the network
doesn't go down true you're more like
it's bringing machine down the new
orders there's pay for the website yes
to run the load yes
most most people do it to keep to keep
the environment alive because it's in
their interest to keep the environment
alive it's not a significant awake make
for say you know ways if you're just
weaning if the specific node you can
meet again you can bring the node down
but you'll never in the never pound we
can connect to any other node
yeah most of what goes on is submitting
transactions yeah right now when you
submit transactions they cost you money
and you ain't gonna ddos by spending
money yeah that's the whole that's the
the whole crux about gas in the first
place and the other thing about gas is
because you have the gas limit yet it
stops you having like infinite loops and
things like that you've run out of gas
yeah but they'll recurring it on
different notes yeah you end up querying
it on the one which is closest to you
most of the time yeah it's if everybody
is going to a single webpage which is
talking to a single provider then you've
got a centralization which wasn't what
you're after in the first place
yeah
so come out with okay if you're paying
such a okay now comes the bit which I
avoided talking about so running a node
is not that expensive I mean I'd rather
know most of the time on my back but
when I turn it on the only time it kept
already time it cost me before there I
did it on mobile I used up all of my
mobile italics in one night
mining is something different the whole
concept of mining like we're still using
the same concepts that we'll put in
place by the Bitcoin is called proof of
work and the aim is to make sure that no
one miner no matter how powerful his
machine mines all the transactions
because if you mind all the transactions
you can rewrite and rewrite the
blockchain nobody would know so in order
to do that then there is an artificial
contest was in place for proof of work
and what that says is that in order to
submit a block you need to make make the
block hash
meet an artificial what's the word
conditional the other so for example we
could say at the moment the numerical
value of the block hash has to be less
than 1,500 or something like that now
obviously if you just randomly select
blocks that's very unlikely to be true
so you're gonna have to reorganize you
can have to change nonce is you gonna
have to keep on trying until you have a
block that meets those conditions and
there aren't that but in all as a reward
for that you get the certain amount of
ether which at the moment is three ether
for the block plus all of the
transaction fees right now the
transaction fee that you pay is the gas
you use multiplied by the price you
offered for the gas right so also coming
into it if I as a minor want to mine a
block I will choose the ones which offer
me the highest gas prices they'll make
the most notes out of that block right
so the miners get paid that's where your
transaction fees go to the miners to
keep the system fair
now they're up there working on
something which is because because it's
a difficult thing to win but it relies
as much on chance as it does on
computing power it tends to get
generally distributed amongst different
miners right
does that find them up sweet transaction
of these ago
the functions are they evaluated once by
the minor and then results of the
function of the new state is that part
of the block or like the function needs
to be valued
every time the computing - okay you did
you submit a transaction which changes
the state of a contract the minor will
prove that that is valid he'll either
prove it succeeds or fails but whatever
happens he will include it in the block
right every node on the network well at
the moment they include it in the block
they will compute the state of the
etherium machine I mean does it cost the
miner more if you have a function that's
very expensive versus a function that's
cheap because what you said is like more
yeah I mean okay every block has got a
gas limit right so you can either have a
few really expensive transactions or a
lot of really cheap transactions
right because you know the whole point
about the gas property or the gas price
of a transaction is that yeah if you've
got a repeated loop which takes a lot of
computing power then that will cost more
than just a simple piece of code if
you've got something which uses a lot of
state variables that is more expensive
than using local memory because it's
more companies yep the computation of
moving information after state variables
that actually higher so the gas the gas
limit you have to provide is actually
based upon how much work has to be done
so to compute a block the miners also
computing these hashes right yeah shout
256 in Bitcoin
it's called catch up to five six years
it's like this close to a three so so I
mean yeah so how does the cost of doing
that compared with the cost of computing
your function even if it has a loop that
runs to a thousand inside it like your
contract might have a function that runs
to a thousand but that's still really
cheap in the scheme of things for the
minor compared to you know computing a
check to 56 like a billion um really
cheap as in walk I have you seen later
CD time well the point is I mean now we
get to economics promote most miners it
still they still economical to do so
otherwise it wouldn't be mining I mean I
mean I I have a mind from the year and a
half but I mean I was making money out
of it obviously other people are people
are looking reducing the costs there's
one project called hydro miner where
they're where they take industrial
containers full of miners they pop them
right next to hydroelectric dams in
Austria and they buy wholesale
electricity from the dam it you know
this far more economical logically
viable for the simple reason that then
you know they're not going anything to
get the electricity
but I mean yes I mean that's why we're
trying to get away we're trying to get
away from proof of work on a theory it
should be sometime in the next year
hopefully that there are one or two
networks out there the acutal network
uses cruise state which means you're not
doing as many computations I don't think
graphic cars to do it in fact on cues
and they say you can actually do you can
actually do mining using a Raspberry Pi
if you want to as effectively as a
mainframe
questions of our
the folk
and it doesn't it doesn't have it
doesn't have any impact on the
blockchain this Jeffs is just it makes
it generates a lot of heat it uses a lot
of power and contributes to global
warming
yeah I really don't go into into that
I'm afraid it's
are you doing ramen yeah okay
yeah we're we're over time but it on
happy overnight
we are more questions do more coding do
whatever you guys want
never trust anything okay rose security
Rose it in in working with on both
changing with any values changes in the
crashing comments contact if anything's
got a server side it means someone to
steal your kids right when you create a
mess emotion wallet it gives you is it
twelve twelve words Yannick yeah it
gives you a monitor in the Manik twelve
words just like the ones you see at the
top there using those my formula called
VIP thirty-nine you can regenerate the
private key public key pair when you get
so meta math tells them you're supposed
to write them down and don't be like the
clever person who stored it in
Ethan and what equal Evernote I mean
anything however no got hacked and so
she lost up her heels she lost her
private keys she loves all that so yeah
but some magic here like for something
if I use the same you money you know you
this is a popular muonic do not use it
your fans right here Rodney money why
[Music]
because they extract like
maybe there's an extra life he's not
where's a female condition 8 years over
it's a root key so I used this 12:12
works thank you sir
[Music]
but you got paste that if you go and
paste it here they give you answers I'm
clean
I'll be 15
so basically in theory should be
creating with the same yes well he bears
I say I'm right now which which I took
unconnected
oh it doesn't matter that doesn't matter
it's just like a bunch of bad taste
losing one important
that is the derivation problem
but given the VIP 39 function it doesn't
get though that phrase does not give you
one address it gives you a sequence of
addresses right so meta mask has it I
say do not store it on a computer
write it down take a photograph of it
with a real camera develop the film
yourself and put it in a safe whatever
you want to do but it certainly does
story and Evernote or something which
could be hacked you have these wallets
that I showed you before which should be
this is a legend a no this is us the
same thing your software can talk to it
through USB cable this does the signing
your little buttons on here when you
first initialize it in an initializer
into a random state it gives you a
24-bit phrase you write it down you
don't write and if you do that you might
also want to think about some way that
you can distribute it to a few relatives
if you pop off wife and family can be
looked after
right security is very important right
so that that now brings us so Mike your
wallets should never have a back-end
most of the phishing attacks that take
place are fake site they are fakes of
sites like money for wallet where they
put a back-end on it they ask you to
upload the JSON file put in the password
which is exactly what message to ask
money so what it does with money Thor
what it does everything in the browser
the moment they've got a back-end they
got your file they've got they've got
your password the next thing you know is
you've lost order easy
yes
today Aaron like requiring this API file
and tracking a bit further
I have one little tuning I still have
one with two t-shirts but I have XXL and
an exit on the XXL in Excel if you've
got any big thing that hit you like a
t-shirt can see me okay
thank you guys for coming hope it was
not really confusing if it was confusing
feel free to continue asking questions
in a chat
pick your patients and follow up ton of
resources online live event yet made a
photo together
oh okay yeah I need a hat